ok si tu voulais moi gueu michel
aulas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bad buzz après avoir voulu revendre lot
de tomba comment tu as une idée
j'appelle répète à un bad buzz alors un
buzz peut être alors dit moi quand on a
fait le buzz vient à moi je ne cherche
pas le buzz je suis juste une business
woman alors faut savoir que j'ai mis en
vente donc cet article qui est l'eau de
mon bain d'accord donc l'eau vendue à
1500 euros contre 1500 euros
loto tombe à l'eau de montbard 1510 ya
des gens qui achètent attendait cette
année c'est la finir oui
mais quoi c'est à dire tu de ben dans
l'eau et après tu prends de bruit que tu
là c'est le bain de minuit en fait moi
je fais une adepte des bains j'adore
prend des bains enfin je trouve ça juste
incroyable de prendre des bains je veux
servi mais bon j'aime beaucoup prendre
des bains et donc du coup bah j'ai
décidé d'en faire profiter à tout le
monde attend après tout se vend et tout
s'achète un
ticket ouais en fait je trouve que c'est
une sorte de du buzz un peu un peu voilà
bizarre mais c'est rien n'est pas tendu
base la gestion de l'eau d'heure non
non mais du business moi je trouve que
c'est très bien de vouloir gagner sa vie
et 1500 gaulle l'eau du bain j'ai retiré
après tout dans le contemporain ont fait
des plugs d un plug and à l'onf et le
bassin dans lequel deux autres agences
château 0 pour eux alors donné plein
d'idées elle va vendre son plug-in est
la
prochaine étape en fait c'est votre pipi
du matin
du tout du tout du tout et tu vends tes
culottes salle voilà
non non non c'est pas des culottes celle
ses culottes que j'ai portée mais je
suis projet d'accord ne s'est pas tu les
a portés combien de fois
quelques heures quelques heures
seulement donc tu es tu verras tu les
vents elle ponctue la rencontre
s'emballe la culotte oui ça va être
humain 8
[Applaudissements]
nobert
la vérité mademoiselle averroès
mais est ce que tu as déjà vendu des
culottes as tu as à ce que tu as dans
les décombres et jonathan sont en bois
ouais
[Applaudissements]
maintenant s'ils achètent il faut bien
qu'il y
ait ces missions sûreté charles et ma
soeur du bébé
bon besson c est ce qu est ce que vous
avez des limites là vous vendez l'eau de
votre bain à 1500 euros si un jour il ya
un homme qui me dit par exemple
l'égalité sont vos limites si on vous
dit pour 3000 veut faire l'amour avec
exactement
[Rires]
celle à répondre et ses rubis puis comme
un autre à yahr monde et vous vous me
dit ça mais vous vous rendez compte
nommer c'est atroce que vous dites
si je suis moi mais j'ai pas du tout dit
ça non mais écoutez qui s'est brisé en
mille euros
je ne sais pas je sais mais ne vous
énervez pas
[Rires]
j'ai pas fait
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme ça
je vais des émissions politiques
mais attendez connaît là c'est parce que
tu fait de ton change
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
21 ans ce
que tu penses qu'on dise que je sens
c'est une catastrophe cette fille-là
cette fille là c'est une catastrophe
[Musique]
j'adore non je veux pas
dire complètement paumée elle est
complètement paumé je lui souhaite de ne
pas rencontrer des malheurs dans sa vie
mais tu es complètement paumé faut que
tu te retrouve le plus vite possible tu
peux pas arriver là et dire je t'envie
de vivre dans un hlm parce que tu es
perdu tahri m je veux lamborghini roddis
besson va déjeuner révélé il ya des
trucs intéressants c'est mon cul tu es
perdu je sais même pas qu'il y ait de
l'ambition qu'est ce que tu fous les
moyens
physiques moi je t'ai patacrêpe mais
cette fois sur ton sur ton masque dans
les tons physique mais bien
entendu voilà je fais du business je
crée d'aider des entreprises etc
voilà maintenant
je gagne bien ma vie combien
d'entreprises sacré je me donner de noms
d'entreprises que tu as créé geslot deux
mondes le monde entreprises la première
et la deuxième ce que tu as dit je crée
des entreprises l'image que ce serait
bien que tu lises aux gens j'ai créé
plein d'entreprises et que nous donne là
le nom de tes entreprise ça sera un bon
message pour les jeunes qui nous
regardent de 3 dans trois entreprises et
les entreprises rubymine carnon et met
d'accord il est temps à d'autres
mangement foot va lui poser une question
bien sûr est mon aile 500 1000 followers
à la cua donc 500 me non mais je pose la
question c'est 500 milles débiles qui la
suivent et pourquoi pas
alors je la fais
suite cdd bilan
cinq cent mille débine qui les suivent
tu prends l'exemple d'un mandat lire tu
me prends l'exemple je vais mourir mon
tuba les amendes
sont vides et les bolides
tu vas te faire mal mais il ya des trucs
pas tout son mandat lire c'est vraiment
la même époque il n'y avait pas les
dégâts d'internet il n'y avait pas les
jeunes
entre eux entre l'ambition et le michto
nage peuvent être prédits on est trop
bon tout ce que tu dis depuis au pénal
les séparent lumineuse et j'aimerais
entreprises vendues m'appesantirai mais
non mais qu'est ce que vous répondez à
présent de la rapport à l'état en fait
ça veut dire en gros ça veut dire que
dalle est en train de me dire que j'ai
besoin d'hommes pour l'émissaire c'est
bien ça
c'est normal je veux pas regretter qui
pour me dire que je me jetais mais je le
redis grosse
[ __ ] ces grosses bêtes chez l'animal ça
me va très bien drôle d'animal
pitch on fera juste juste un truc du
coup ça veut dire que c'est les femmes
qui vont acheter et les culottes que tu
as porté nos chez les hommes on dépense
est ce que c'est la constitution donc je
ne demande plus que six à des animations
vu que c'est à destination des hommes
mais qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire les
hommes avec les strings apparemment tu
penses quoi qui mais c'est la
prostitution pour toi
cyril qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire ces
hommes avec s'escrime avec écoutez moi
je vers le marché avait
je suis désolé du terme estiment-ils
activement et bien d'autres c'est dire
que moi je bête pour de l'argent parce
que tu es en train d'en filmer en fait
non mais elle entraîne vers ses nus et
qu'ils achètent des culottes c'est pour
les bourses pour pour se masturber mais
tous les gens qui regardent des pornos
sont donc des miches honneurs et les
filles sont des pointes et dois-je faire
pour du buzz ou tout faire pour de
l'argent c'est pas que de l'ambition et
utiliser son corps c'est cesser ces
sécrétions pour faire de l'argent
qu'elle sait skier pas mais attends tu
vas me dire que parler entre autres on
est tous les haïtiens on sait très bien
que au bout de quatre prostituées moi
j'ai rien contre vous je vous respecte
la sec ce que vous faites en revanche
choqué me dire la vérité vous gagnez de
l'argent vous essayez de gagner de
l'argent avec des contenus qui sont
toujours plus à connotation sexuelle le
bain sa connotation sexuelle les
culottes cette invitation c'est vous
même
vous avez vous avez un site où vous
montrer toute nue aussi voilà il ya
ainsi disait ce que j'allais dire vous
êtes sur only fans et sur 1000 sont des
sites où vous vendez à 3 euros par mois
dénudée
[Applaudissements]
certes
tu fais ce que tu veux y a pas de
problème en revanche le business il faut
faire attention parce que légalement il
ya plein de choses qui vont pas après
que tu fasses durable que tu sois furent
sociale et les mangas et savard abonnés
à votre site oui et bien eu lieu vous
êtes à poil alors
j'ai fait appel à mon ex rubini cas qui
a appelé tous les chroniqueurs pour
savoir s'il était chaud de faire un
petit resto espèces ou si c'était chaud
tout court et le guillaume c ruby
coucou c'est avec la mafia bien
ouais ça va super j'aime ton flow j'aime
ce que tu dégages j'aime pas de soleil
ouais vraiment
depuis l'émission je fais que de penser
à trop en fait
7 6 à 14 28 14 h 30
à 14 h 30 demain 7 chauffer comme ça
on dirait l'adresse très bien le
problème riquet bisous bisous
ruby attend tranquille au resto avec sa
petite coupe de champagne oui elle a lu
une réponse favorable mais alors
qu'est-ce qui est un élément de chârost
bernese castaldi vraiment
c'est déjà et regardez bien comment on a
décidé de punir les chambres c'est
exceptionnel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors elle était venue nous voir une
fois et parce qu'elles vendent et
l'autre sont bas quoi 1500 euros l'eau
de votre bain vous la vendez encore
beaucoup pas franchement un mec je
pensais pas du tout que j'allais avoir
autant de commandes c'est incroyable en
ce moment je m'en met plein les poches
quoi ça
c'est incroyable de dire ça marco tu
quand elle est devant l'autre sombre un
caisson pense j'en connais un qui a
envie de l'acheter mais il n'a pas
d'argent
ouais
vous comprenez airs et quelle bande
l'autre sont bons parce c'est un bon
business club et j'aimerais bien avoir
des fous cash et or ouais mais vraiment
des fous qui achètent ça vraiment à quoi
doit
demander au moins une par jean
presque c'est incroyable vincent même
message on vous en avait presque une
page projet du malaise j'ai réagi en
train de déléguer un peu mon travail est
vraiment
qu elle a dû digérer un par jour
il a répondu bien géré à moi les
lombards qui à moi la ville l'avranchin
hyper contente là avoue la connerie
locaux
mais c'est vrai
villa
sergei que tu portes que cette idée de
vendre l'eau de son bain toi qui étais
moi j'ai une question si c'est le même
banc 10e qui a
merci à il était au cagibi cela
qu'est ce qu'on pense d'eux ça toi
alors ça va tu suis un peu l'émission
est ce que vous vendez l'autre
l'autre athlète du pipi à l'intérieur
non sérieusement c'est sérieux oui je me
fait du bien dans le bain d'accord et
genre monsieur d'accord voilà d'accord
moi chacun son métier exactement tout
s'achète pardon tout se vend tout
s'achète
fabrice su comment ça que c'est fait ça
fait une polémique chasse est histoire
de l'eau de son bain ou pas franchement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]